[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar how to leverage laser capture
micro dissection technology for advanced
oncology research
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
katie walter phd field application
scientist thermo fisher scientific
dr walter you may now begin your
presentation
well thank you everyone for being here
today as i'm very excited to get to
present to you an exciting technology
known as laser capture micro dissection
or lcm on our latest arcturus instrument
and showcase how utilizing lcm in
oncology research can help advance our
understanding of the complexities
involved in cancer development and
progression
as far as my background goes i am from
the midwest based in kansas city
missouri which is where i got my
undergraduate degree
after that i decided to head south to
charleston south carolina to get my
masters in biomedical science where i
did a lot of hands-on transcript and
protein analysis and hormone receptor
positive breast cancer
after that rather than go to medical
school like i had planned i realized i
did love research so my next step was to
get my phd which i did at the university
of kansas medical center here in kansas
city as a part of the ku cancer center
which just last month achieved
comprehensive status so a little shout
out to them
my dissertation project investigated how
the progesterone receptor influences
gene expression of immune modulators in
breast cancer so again a lot of genetic
analysis in the form of chip seek
rna-seq and qpcr
so this experience led me to
thermo-fisher after i graduated where
i've now been for over two years and am
loving it
as a field application scientist i cover
our sequencing platforms
um including our next generation
platform ion torrent as well as our
capillary electrophoresis instruments
used for sanger sequencing and fragment
analysis
and then i cover lcm which is of course
the focus of our discussion today
so i give presentations like this i also
like to give some non-science related
background just for fun before we get
into the nitty gritty of the of this
talk
um so this is what i spend my free time
doing i have two office mates named
beacon and ivy you may very well hear
during this presentation so i apologize
in advance chalk it up to the joys of
remote work
um my favorite job besides being a
scientist is being an answer three of
the coolest kids on this planet
um i am a uh born and raised die hard
cheese fan uh this picture with my mom
is from the afc championship game where
the chiefs won and booked passage to the
first super bowl of my lifetime
um and then here is my husband and i uh
freezing our tails off at the parade
after we won the super bowl
all right let's get into the meat of the
presentation so here are the general
topics that i'll be discussing today
first i plan to give give a thorough
introduction to lcm for anyone who is
unfamiliar with the basics of the
technology
and how using our uh dual laser system
in the arcturus select is preferable
over single laser systems
i'll also touch on workflow and
consumable options just so you're able
to visualize how lcm could fit into your
existing workflow then i'll move into
discussing why using lcm's advantageous
and oncology research in particular and
how it can be used to address tumor
heterogeneity and the complexities of
the tumor microenvironment
and then i'll finish up with some real
research that has been published
utilizing our technology and oncology
research
so first let's discuss lcm beginning
with a short history lesson
lcm as a technology has been around for
about 25 years and was the result of a
collaboration between bioengineers and
cancer pathologists located at the nih
it was first published on in 1996
in science where lance leota's group
sought to address a known issue in the
then blossoming genetic analysis field
and that was that despite advances in
genomic research they required pure
pure populations to make that data
meaningful
and up until that point microdissection
involved a very manual process that was
time consuming unprecise and very
specialized and that required a high
degree of manual dexterity
basically it was not efficient
or economical enough to be a mainstay in
their workflow
so they developed a technology that
utilized a transparent film over their
tissue side and then used a focus pulse
from an infrared laser to adhere the
film to the tissue
that transfer film with the attached
tissue was then used for dna or rna
analysis
so these first these first lcm
instruments were a makeshift microscope
with an attached laser but they were
still able to show that they could
dissect out tissue from fresh frozen
samples farmland fixed paraffin embedded
samples and psychology samples and
successfully isolate quality nucleic
acids
from the second paper in science by that
same group they commercialized the
instrument and made substantial
improvements to the process by attaching
the transfer film to caps that can be
precisely placed on the tissue by a
mechanical arm
this commercialized instrument was the
start of the arcturus company and the
lcm patent was licensed to arcturus in
1996
and since then there are various
instruments that have been released
beginning with the the pixel which then
moved on to the autopics
followed by the veritas uh the release
of the arcturus xt instrument happened
in 2007 which was then improved upon
with this release in 2012.
so since then the arcturus product line
had been fairly quiet um until last year
when we launched our brand new
streamlined laser capture micro
dissection instrument the arcturus
select
and here i want to highlight specific
features of the arctur select so as you
can see the the instrument or the
footprint of the instrument and the
monitor is minimized in this newest
model when you compare it to some of our
older instruments
in this reduction in space
required partly comes from the fact that
the instrument itself
houses an onboard computer with a
windows 10 operating system
you'll see this ultra hd monitor which
functions as a display for that onboard
computer system
this monitor is a touch screen that
works with the provided stylus to make
up marking areas of interest that much
easier
and the trackball makes it quick and
easy to maneuver around the tissue side
and then of course you have the option
to use traditional mouse mouse and
keyboard
and i just want to add that all these
accessories are included with the
instrument
so as for the instrument itself it has a
2x 4x 10x 20x 40x and 60x objective
the objectives as well as the stage
position and cap robot arm are all
automated through the arcturus software
so the only manual of step of the
process is loading the stage with your
slides and caps at the very beginning
everything else is going to be
controlled through that software
in addition the instrument has an
integrated camera system that allows for
documentation of the lcm process
by being able to take pictures or videos
at any point while micro dissecting
as for imaging it contains an led bright
field as well as an optional
fluorescence that contains red green and
blue channels
and of course we are talking about a
laser capture system and as such the
select like our previous system
has that dual laser technology which
i'll elaborate on in the next few slides
so how exactly does lcm work so i
already told you about the original
technology that utilized a transfer film
and an infrared laser
to stick the tissue of instrument
interest to that film
so since then we have of course
improved upon this technology and have
added another laser so that second laser
is a high powered ultraviolet or uv
laser that can precisely cut a round
tissue of interest to ensure complete
removal of the sample to be analyzed
so having both lasers at your disposal
on a single instrument allows for
flexibility in the types of tissues that
can be successfully captured on the
arcturus select
so now let's take a look at a closer
look at each individual laser um and how
they function and then we'll bring both
of them together and show you how they
work in conjunction with each other
so the first laser we'll take a closer
look at is the infrared or ir laser so
this particular laser is about as
is about as powerful as a laser pointer
so it really is gentle enough to isolate
single cells without damaging tissue or
compromising nucleic acid integrity
and the key to successful ir capture is
the thermoplastic polymer that coats the
bottom of the cap which is shown here as
this green line so this is analogous to
that transfer film that the original
inventors of lcm used to capture their
tissue
so the way this works is that the ir
laser fires from above
the polymer of on the cap absorbs that
energy which causes it to predictably
distend down
towards your tissue where it will adhere
to the cells of interest
then when the cap is lifted with the
automated cap arm the tissue is stuck to
the cap and is completely removed from
the side so you can think of this
polymer as almost a selective scotch
tape that prevents that laser energy
from directly contacting the sample
so here's a visual of how that polymer
distends down to capture the tissues
this is a scanning electron a scanning
electron microscopy image showing a
single cell capture
so you can see over the bottom of the
cap would be which is right here so when
that ir laser fires from above this
polymer is descending down
toward the tissue and is able to able to
pick up the cell of interest so that
when we lift off that cap lift the cap
up off the tissue we're left with our
cell attached to that selective scotch
tape
and depending on the type of cap you use
the size of the cell that can be
captured can be as little as 10 to 15
microns in diameter
a major benefit of using the ir laser is
that it allows for single cell capture
without damaging the morphology of the
cells and you can see that here in these
lcm pictures of wrap grain stained using
our histid gene staining kit
so in this case the target of interest
were these particular neurons shown here
after laser capture we can see that we
have full removal of these cells as
they're no longer present in the
original tissue
and when we look at the surface of the
cap at the quality check station on the
instrument we can see that we do have
the four cells captured onto the cap
and because the select uses this cat
polymer to capture cells you never lose
custody of your sample and that can be
documented throughout the process like
we've shown here
additionally you'll notice that adjacent
tissue so the tissue that we do not want
to capture we're not impacted in the
overall morphologies and is maintained
and that really is because that ir laser
is so gentle
and so the final point i would like to
make is that using only the ir laser um
uh using only the iron laser
functionality is only really ideal for
single cell applications but it can be
used for bigger pieces of tissue if the
tissue is soft and easily dissectable
all right so next we have the uv laser
which is more the workhorse of micro
dissection so it's fast it's precise and
it's useful for cutting out large
sections of tissue so think a group of
cells or specific blood vessel
within the tissue or normal tissue
within a tumor cross section really the
list can go on
um it is also helpful for when you're
trying to cut something hard like bone
or something that loves to stick to a
slight like connective tissue
and another use for the uv laser is you
can use it to simply get rid of
materials on a slide or to ablate a
barrier around the tissue you actually
want to collect
so one caveat to using the uv laser is
that it requires the use of a specific
side type that is coated with a
polyethylene absolutely membrane or pen
membrane
to facilitate this cutting process
and we offer a couple different versions
of pen membrane slides and they can be
used for mounting tissue like you would
with standard glass slides so there's
really not much disruption to your
normal workflow if you've changed up the
slide type
so whereas the ir laser fires from above
to make that cap film sticky
the uv laser fires from below where it
cuts through the pen membrane which is
shown here as this blue line between the
slide and the tissue
this cutting of the membrane releases
the tissue and allows it to stick to the
cap film
so just like when you use the ir laser
only you maintain custody of that sample
as it stays on the bottom of this cap
until you're ready to extract out your
nucleic acid
so i've explained this far how each
laser works individually but when
performing
when performing laser
laser capture experiment you're most
likely going to utilize both lasers
and this short video here will help
explain how you go about doing that
so the first thing that will happen is
the automated cap arm will place a fresh
capture cap on the location that you
specified in the
software
then taking a closer look at the tissue
we can mark up areas that we wish to
capture
so in this first section of tissue we
can use the mouse or stylus to mark up
the perimeter of our area of interest
and the software automatically sets a uv
cut line where the laser will cut around
our tissue
the software will also automatically add
in ir spots which when used in
conjunction with the uv laser act more
as tact points so that we can ensure
that the piece of tissue comes off in
one piece and maintains its morphology
so in this next piece of tissue that is
marked it is just showing that you can
switch up the order in which the lasers
fire so in the first case the ir fired
first to create that contact with the
cap and then the uv laser released the
tissue by cutting through the membrane
so here the uv laser will fire first and
then higher spots are added manually
after
and then of course you can use iron
laser alone to capture single cells
so after we have dissected everything we
want the automated cap arm lifts the cap
off off the tissue and you can see that
the morphology is maintained and you
have custody of your sample throughout
the whole
process so as i've already mentioned the
dual laser system adds that flexibility
and that you can dissect out a variety
of tissues in cell types
so to add to that flexibility of the
system and the workflow as a whole
we have specific consumables available
to meet your particular needs
so first beginning with the
caps themselves
we offer three different cap types two
are shown here and then we'll talk about
the third on the next slide
so here we have our macro and our micro
caps
um and the biggest distinction between
the two is the type of tube that they
will fit into so the macro caps will fit
directly into a half mil a centrifuge
tube while the micro caps can fit into
either a half mil or a 200 microliter
microcentrifuge too
and the size of the tube is important
because it dictates what volume of
extraction buffer is needed to extract
your cells from the cap after micro
dissection which i'll discuss here in a
few slides
so as for the slides themselves we have
three different options as well so first
is the standard glass side which i've
highlighted here that they must be
uncharged
any sort of charge will cause tissue to
stick to the slide and not come off onto
the cap
remember that if you want to use the uv
laser you need a pen membrane slide and
we have two options for those this is a
standard glass slide with the pen
membrane and then we have a metal uh
framed pen membrane slide that is
usually utilized for
more specialized applications
so speaking of specialized applications
our third cap type enables isolation of
delicate or rare cell types
these caps are called high sensitivity
or hs caps and are differentiated from
macro and micro cuts by the fact that
they have these standoff rails on the
bottom of the cap so this holds the cap
12 microns above your capture area
so why does this help when dissecting
delicate tissues
well first the rails ensure that there's
actually no direct contact between the
cap
um
between the cap and the tissue so if you
have delicate tissue this helps ensure
that nothing is accidentally sticking to
the bottom of that cap
additionally because this cap is held
further above the tissue when that ir
laser fires from above and causes
distension of that film
the point at which the film meets the
tissue is a much smaller
which allows for the dissection of cells
as small as 10 to 15 microns in diameter
and after you dissected your cells and
captured them onto the bottom of that hs
cap rather than put them into a
centrifuge tube like you do with the
other types of caps these come with
something called an extracture device
shown here which allows you to pipet
extraction buffer directly onto the
cells which ensures that you don't end
up over diluting your samples when
dealing with rare cell types
so how the 12 micron rails work can be
difficult to visualize
um so i wanted to include this short
video that shows how capturing with an
hs cap works
so the cap is placed just like any other
cap using automated cap arm
but when the cap is placed you can see
how those standoff rails keep the
capture area from coming in contact with
the cap itself
so here um
it's showing how you can use the ir
laser alone to capture a group of cells
so this ir laser fires from above causes
that distension of the cat polymer
towards the tissue
like i said on the previous slide since
it is 12 microns above the point at
which the film contacts the tissue is
smaller than if uh using our other types
of caps which allow for the capture of
smaller cell types
and then after capturing you have your
tissue on the cap and the extraction of
ice that comes with the hs cap seals
around where the tissue is collected
and then you pipet directly into the
device with only 10 microliters of
extraction buffer needed which again
helps keep you from over diluting your
samples when performing nucleic acid
extraction and downstream analysis
so last video um
i showed your last video showed how
extraction works with an hs cap so i do
also have one showing how it work with
our other caps
um
fitting them directly into micro
microcentrifuge tubes
so when it comes to extraction we offer
a variety of different kits that can be
used to isolate out your nucleic acid of
interest
including
um this paradise line which is specific
to isolating rna from formal infects
paraffin embedded samples which of
course are more difficult to work with
because of the complications fixation
poses to rna integrity
these kits are mostly column based with
the exception of this magmax kit which
is a magnetic bead base
kit and you also have the flexible of
utilizing other extraction kits after
you've dissociated yourselves from the
cap
so once you've completed extraction the
rest of the workflow is up to you and is
essentially uncoupled from the lcm
instrument at this point
so many applications that we see
customers using lcm for anything related
to genetic analysis so think next-gen
sequencing singer sequencing microarrays
qpcr and it's not restricted to the
instruments shown here
these are just examples offered by
thermofisher
the only consideration you need to worry
about at this point is ensuring that for
whatever application you are using lcm4
that you have enough starting material
to input into these various workflows
all right hopefully so far we've gained
a good baseline understanding of the
technology itself so now let's discuss
how lcm fits into oncology research
initially you may be wondering why it's
necessary to go through these extra
steps before performing genetic analysis
on tumor samples but the reality of the
situation is that looking at pure
populations is far more informative than
when looking at mixed populations like
you would get from traditional methods
like doing a whole tissue scrape of a
histology slide or whole cell lysate
and the complexities of oncology
research make this particular field of
study one of the biggest users of lcm
when we're able to study these pure
populations
we are able to uncover those hidden
molecular signals from specific cell
types within the disease state we are
investigating
and when looking at oncology research in
particular lcm can help address the
complexities of the tumor
microenvironment as well as tumor
heterogeneity
so the tumor microenvironment is not
represented by the cancer cells alone
but by the various other cells involved
in either supporting or combating the
tumor's progression
so these cells include various types of
infiltrating immune cells blood vessels
used to support the growing tumor
extracellular matrix and of course the
transformed cancer cells themselves
the cells comprising the tumor stroma
communicate with the tumor and vice
versa leading to specific gene
expression cytokine signaling and
immunoediting
so when we think about this in the
context of traditional methods of
genetic analysis we generally would
homogenize a whole tumor section before
moving into nucleic acid or protein
isolation
and the consequence of this is that less
abundant cell types in the tumor
microenvironment
despite potentially being major players
in tumor progression are muted in your
final results
so not only do we have to consider the
differing cell types between the tumor
and the stroma we have to consider that
the tumor cells themselves are not all
genetically identical
so when this figure adapted from the
this 2021 paper in cancers it
illustrates how mutations accumulate in
this clonal evolution process
so as
as time passes and as a tumor grows
factors stemming from the
microenvironment or from even treatment
itself can induce evolution and select
for certain mutations that promote tumor
progression
so through this process we end up with a
tumor containing various types of cancer
cells with distinct genetic mutations
that could potentially alter how a tumor
will respond to therapeutic
interventions
so much like i discussed on the previous
slide when we employ traditional methods
of studying a tumor we are looking at
the tumor as a whole and not at the
individual cell types making up that
tumor
so again we'll end up muting the gene
signatures of less abundant cancer cells
as the more abundant mutations will
drown those out in your final results
so let's take a look a look at a
specific example that illustrates this
concept
so this is an example of a study that
was performed using the arcturus xt for
micro dissection
so here you see a cross section of a
formula fixed paraffin-embedded tumor
sample lung tumor sample rv
where pathologists identified different
regions of the tumor that showed
markedly different cell morphologies
they're labeled here as regions one two
and three where regions one and two are
adenocarcinomas in region 3 is a
carcinoid
after they performed microdissection of
these specific regions they extracted
dna out using our picopure extraction
kit which is one of those column-based
kits i spoke about earlier
and with that dna they used um two
different or they performed next
generation sequencing on one of our ion
torrent systems and they used two
different amplitude targeted sequencing
panels the first the colon and lung
research panel and then the oncoming
cancer research panel
so first using the london colon cancer
research panel which is a targeted panel
that interrogates 22 different genes
known to be involved in disease
progression
using this panel they found two
different pathogenic alleles um one in
k-ras and one in p53
and the abundance of each mutation is
plotted here among the three different
regions as well as the whole tissue
scrape
with the krf mutation shown in blue and
then the p53 mutation shown in red
so when just looking at k-rest you can
see that expression varied among the
three different regions
with the adenocarcinoma region so
regions one and two showing the highest
rate of mutation versus the carcinoid
region
so then when you look at the whole
tissue scrape it takes on what
essentially would be the average between
those three different three different
regions
so you really lose the significant
differences between these distinct
tissue types
and we see a similar situation with p53
where abundance in region two is over
double what is present in regions one
and three um
as well as what is represented in the
whole tissue straight
so because the oncoming cancer research
panel looks at more low side than the
colon and lung cancer panel does it
revealed a much greater degree of
heterogeneity throughout this particular
tumor section
so in this particular sample there were
a total of 49 variants found which are
shown across the x-axis of this graphic
and the frequency of each allele among
the three different pathological
sections vary tremendously so to
illustrate this the researchers plotted
out the relative frequencies in this
chart shown here
such that green bars pointing down uh
indicate the frequency of that
particular allele being below average
and then red bars pointing upward
indicate a frequency higher than average
they then group them according to
similar distribution patterns
so it's clear that there are distinct
differences in expression of these
alleles among the different sections
when compared to each other as well as
the whole tissue scrape and i've
highlighted a few areas that really
illustrate this difference
so this group of alleles on the left are
at a much higher frequency in this
carcinoid section
when compared to the adenocarcinoma
sections
but when looking at the whole tissue
scrape you can't tease out these
differences anymore
similarly with the box on the right
region two has much higher frequency of
these low wheels whereas regions one and
three do not
um and the whole tissue script ends up
averaging out the frequency of these
alleles
and finally the chart to the right
demonstrates how many more unique
variants we were able to identify when
uh when we look at specific sections of
the tumor using lcm versus looking at
the tumor as a whole with using a
traditional whole tissue scrape
and to hammer this helmet even more they
even used a custom rna amplicity panel
to look at rna expression of 53
different genes so keep in mind that
this is from formalin fix paraffin
embedded tissue showing that quality rna
is attainable with our system
even from these difficulty sequence
samples
so this heat map here is illustrating
the changes in gene expression
throughout our three different sections
compared to the whole tissue scrape
and again it's clear that precision
genetic analysis is crucial in
applications such as this so that we can
tease out these distinct differences
which in oncology research can mean a
difference in diagnosis treatment plan
and prognosis
some previous study focused on sections
of the tumor based on pathology
but what about honing down even further
and getting to a single cell level
this study here was sort of a proof of
concept study to show that single cells
isolated using an arcturus instrument
can be successfully sequenced
and this was done on one of our next
generation sequencing platforms but
would theoretically apply to other
sequencing or genetic analysis
applications as well
so in this particular study the research
goodness the researchers employed one of
our specialized slide types this frame
membrane slide
so this type of slide does not have any
glass portion so this metal frame
encapsulates the pen membrane only so
it's almost like if you had saran wrap
stretched across uh this metal frame
because of the type of slide um because
of this this type of slide can be used
on cultured cells
just shown here in the um the second
panel
so basically the frame creates a chamber
where cells can grow on um so you'd have
this slide placed in tissue culture dish
and then the cells would grow on top of
the membrane
and when ready to micro dissect a cover
slip is used to close off
or is used to close off uh the chamber
and it's placed on the instrument upside
down
um so when you bring the cap on it's
sitting directly on the pen membrane
when the cells adhere to it
um so the ir laser will fire from above
the cat polymer again will distend down
toward that pen membrane and attaches to
where the cells of interest lie
after this attachment occurs the uv
laser fires from below and cuts out that
section of membrane so it will release
when the cap is moved off the slide
which you can see here
the cells used in the study were a549
lung adenocarcinoma cells and they
compared the single cell capture using
the arcturus instrument that was then
subjected to a whole genome
amplification to a pool of a549 cells
they sequenced using an ion torrent next
generation sequencing system and our
targeted amplitude cancer hotspot panel
and when comparing the single cell and
the coolant cells they did observe a
lower depth of coverage in some regions
with the single cell type
which can be somewhat anticipated when
using whole genome amplification as you
run the risk of partial amplification
failure or random non-amplified regions
and allele dropouts
so despite the weakness of this
particular methodology they're able to
identify 11 variants in both the single
cell popular both the single cell and
population of cells
there were five snips that varied but
maybe due to the low depth of coverage i
mentioned because of that whole genome
amplification method
either way the singles this single cell
study established it was indeed possible
to get a large amount of data out of a
very small sample
like i said multiple times throughout
this presentation so far the ability to
sequence single cells in oncology
research is imperative to address the
complexities of the tumor
microenvironment as well as tumor
heterogeneity
um so what's beneficial about using lcm
versus other single cell methods is that
you have the ability to utilize archival
tissue which is fairly common in cancer
research to have these large tissue
banks with varying tumor types at your
disposal
so in this study they actually performed
rna sequencing on single cells isolated
from mastectomy specimens that were
exhibiting
ductal carcinoma in situ which is a type
of early breast cancer that has not yet
become invasive
so while the previous study used live
cell culture for their single cell
capture these researchers isolated
single cells from formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue
so on this first figure shown here you
can see the original piece of tissue
the target cell is outlined in green but
i know it's difficult to see so i added
this area to help identify that
particular cell
in panel b you can see the tissue post
micro dissection where the cell is
completely gone
and then in the inset
you can see um the cell on the bottom of
the cap
they also stain for a macrophage marker
cd 163 shown here um and they isolated
out drama macrophages to compare genetic
signatures among the two distinct cell
types within that tumor micro
environment
so researchers in the study used a
method that they coined as smart 3-seek
to generate their cdna libraries to be
sequenced
so if you're interested in learning more
about that particular protocol i
encourage you to go read this paper
but in short they essentially build upon
the template switching reverse
transcription trick of smartseek and
smart c2 to generate their
double-stranded cdna from tiny amounts
of polyadenylated rna
only in this method they fragment prior
to cdna conversion rather than after
which just makes it more of a streamline
process than the previous protocols
so now on to some of their results so in
figure 4c they're showing gene
expression of known macrophage or dcis
markers and different types of isolated
tissue
so when you see a circle for the data
point it indicates that they're taking
data from bulk processed tissue which
they define as 100 to 500 cells
whereas the triangles are from single
cell isolation
the color indicates
which type of tissue is isolated whether
it was
whether it's from the dcis cancer cells
or
the adjacent macrophages
the circle dcis samples are ones lacking
herb2 amplification which the
researchers mentioned are most likely
intraductal macrophages
so what they found was that
the single cell samples from the same
tissue type match the gene expression
from the bulk samples so when looking at
the macrophage markers you can see that
the macrophage samples clustered
together
along with those cells that were most
likely those intraductal macrophages and
you see a similar phenotype when looking
at
commonly expressed dcis markers
then they moved on to see if they can
use single cell data to identify
distinct populations of cells so they
performed a t-sne analysis and found
that the five ductal cells whose gene
expression resembled those macrophages
did indeed cluster with the stroma
macrophage cells and the bulk macrophage
samples
so this figure is from that same paper
and it's a great depiction of what i've
been hammering home thus far and that
utilizing traditional isolation
techniques for downstream genetic
analysis can leave out significant
pieces of the puzzle
so here they show common way for
performing rna-seq on tumor tissue that
involves the bulk homogenization process
before moving into rna sequence the rna
sequencing workflow
so not only do you miss low abundant
gene signatures when performing the
experiment this way but you also miss
out on being able to see the relative
location or spatial morphology of
specific cell types that you get when um
that you get when using lcm
so in the method that the researchers of
this paper used they could micro dissect
out specific cell populations within the
tumor microenvironment which can inform
as to why certain gene signatures are
present in a particular cell
all right one more paper i want to
quickly touch on is the first two i
discussed really focused on doing single
cell isolation and sequencing um but
what about comparing you know regions of
a tumor in order to address um changes
in gene expression within the tumor
microenvironment
so remember that the tumor micro
environment contains the cancer cells
themselves as well as the stroma which
is made up of a variety of cell types
such as immune cells endothelial cells
extracellular matrix among others
so in this paper researchers sought to
determine how particular gene signatures
of cells within the tumor
microenvironment correlate with cell
signaling pathways in order to get a
clear snapshot of the molecular
differences in the tumor
microenvironment between a rare form of
breast cancer known as invasive globular
carcinoma or ilc
anatomically ilc
is a type of again a rare form of breast
cancer that develops within the milk
producing lobules of the breast a more
common type of breast cancer is invasive
ducts of carcinoma which develops in the
ducts of the breast which they do in
this paper compare the molecular
signatures between these two subtypes
so here just shows a schematic of their
papers what they did was take 23 fresh
frozen
invasive globular carcinoma samples then
used laser capture micro dissection with
one of our arcturus instruments to
separate the stroma populations
from the tumor epithelium
they were primarily focused on
cancer-associated fibroblasts so these
cells were the targets of their stromal
microdissection
they then isolated rna from each
population of cells and performed
microarray analysis to look at gene
expression patterns across the samples
i did want to highlight one of their
supplementary figures
as they utilize the camera on the
arcturus instrument to document the
laser capture process which is a great
feature for when you're looking to
publish your data generated from this
method
so here you see a couple different
samples on the left is a sample that
they are isolating out the tumor
epithelium so you can see the original
sample on top
the middle picture shows the sample
after dissection
and then the bottom shows what was
captured onto the capture cap
similarly on the right you see a sample
of the isolated tumor stroma from and
again you can see all three stages
documented using that onboard instrument
camera
now to look at a little bit of the data
that they generated using this process
if you want to see all of their data i
highly recommend going to read this
whole paper as well
so now they have their two distinct
populations that they've dissected out
and separated the tumor epithelium and
the tumor stroma
like i said they performed an rna
microarray to look at the differential
gene expression among the populations
which is depicted in this heat map here
um they found over a thousand genes that
were significantly highly expressed in
the stromal population and 837 genes in
the tumor epithelium
and when they looked at specific
molecular pathways that these genes were
involved in they found that for the
stromal compartment
they saw an upregulation of genes
involved in ecm remodeling and cell
surface interactions while the tumor
epithelium showed
up regulation of genes development cell
cycle progression dna replication
epigenetic modifications
so before i wrap up i did want to touch
on a really neat specialized application
that we support on the arcturus
instrument that is relevant to oncology
and that is lifestyle micro dissection
using our micro dissection growth
chambers
so i know the first paper i discussed
today did a lifestyle dissection they
used a frame membrane slide as the
growth chamber so another option that we
have is using this petri dish system
that has two parts
so the first is this growth chamber
where the bottom is entirely made up of
pen membrane so that same pen membrane
that's used on those slides
the second piece is the micro dissection
petri dish this bottom is solid but it's
coated with silicone
and the way the system works is you
place your growth chamber
in a standard tissue culture plate and
you grow your cells like normal
when you've either reached some fluency
or whatever end point you're looking for
you remove that growth chamber and place
it into the sterile micro dissection
petri dish
so those two together are placed into
are placed onto the instrument with a
specific petri dish stage insert which
is included with the instrument
and to dissect with this system you
utilize the uv laser so you cut around
your cells of interest which releases
those cells from the growth chamber and
sticks them to the silicone coated
bottom of the petri dish
so when you're finished and you separate
out those two elements you're left with
two separate populations the ones you've
dissected which are now on the bottom of
that petri dish and the ones that are
left behind which are still in the
growth chamber
so from there you can actually
trypsinize and reculture either
population of cells and it does not
affect nucleic acid viability as we
showed here
so this is an example that comes from
one of our white papers um showing that
um
showing cells that were micro dissected
um using the system are able to be uh
re-cultured and even 48 hours post-micro
dissection we can still isolate out good
quality rna as shown here by these
bio-analyzer traces
as cell culture is such a vital tool in
oncology research
as i know it was for me
this vastly opens the possibilities that
lcm can be used for in your specific
research workflow
and when it comes to documenting your
micro dissection process we again make
it very easy and straightforward to take
pictures throughout using that built-in
camera system
so you can see here we have a variety of
tissues and stain types that can be
micro dissected
where a picture was taken prior to micro
dissection which is this top row
which i do want to add you can actually
take pictures that have your drawings
overlaid on your tissue so you can see
where you've marked up cells that you're
interested in
micro dissecting
then you can show the tissue after micro
dissection to demonstrate what was
actually picked up
and then of course with the quality
control station on the instrument you
can take pictures of the bottom of the
caps themselves to show the cells that
were indeed micro dissected
you also have the flexibility of
document using video if that's something
you need for publication or maybe
teaching purposes
all right so wrapping up with a brief
summary of what i've covered today um
first we discussed uh the lcm technology
using the arcturus select
which with its dual laser capability
allows for the flexibility of types of
tissues that can be micro dissected do
hard tissue like bone soft delicate
tissue they're both doable with this
type of system
we also add flexibility to the workflow
through our various types of caps and
slides so that we can meet your specific
experimental needs
we also of course heavily focused on how
lcm can be used specifically in oncology
research as it's a great way to tease
apart differences within the tumor
whether you're addressing tumor
heterogeneity to your micro environment
or both
and finally at thermal fissure we're
able to provide you with everything you
might need for the workflow from
consumables staining kits extraction
kits and even genomic analysis
instruments
and if you're looking for more lcm
resources from us you can visit the
laser capture micro dissection section
on our website at thermofisher.com um
where you can get an overview of the
select system introductions to the
workflow where to order consumables and
we even have a
resource page specific to oncology
research
i highly recommend taking a look around
that page or reaching out to us for any
specific questions you may have
regarding your particular research
applications
so thank you so much for joining me
today listening to me speak on this
topic and i hope you found that useful
and that some of you are considering
utilizing this really neat technology to
further your oncology research
thank you dr walter for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
can high sensitivity caps be used for
dissecting larger areas macro dissection
and would it need pen coded slides if a
lab does not want to change the workflow
too much
also is the extraction process flexible
or pico pure is the only downstream
extraction method
yup so that is a great question i'm
going to kind of hit each one of those
smaller questions within it um so the
first one can high sensitivity caps be
used for dissecting larger areas
you can dissect as large as you can for
that capture area on those caps so those
high sensitivity caps because they have
those rails
um they the actual capture area is gonna
be much smaller than if you're gonna be
using one of our macro or micro caps
so um our macro and micro cups are
around a little over four thousand
microns uh wide whereas the hs capture
area is going to be roughly half i'm
blanking on the exact
exact number but it is going to be
smaller so when you're talking about
macro dissection that's going to be your
limitation there
as far as needing the pen membrane
coated slides that's only um necessary
if you're using uh the uv laser for that
so if you wanted to try and dissect out
just using the ir laser alone like if
you remember that video
um that showed how the hs caps um
how those capture that was actually
showing example uh capturing with just
the eye or laser um so it is possible
um and then the extraction process it is
also very flexible so once you have
um those cells dissociated from
um
from that bottom of the cap you can run
it through any sort of dna or rna
extraction method that you're looking at
the only
consideration is going to be that you're
going to be working with a very small um
sample type so
you know the
bigger the
extraction application you may start to
lose precious products so that's the
only thing you really need to think
about
in regards to that
but good question
all right thank you
our next question can you use the
histigine staining kit for pen membrane
slides the same as you would for glass
slides
simple answer yes you can so um the
histigine staining kit works for both um
both glass as well as henry pet membrane
slides um one of the benefits of using
our using a pen number slide really
doesn't alter your workflow too much the
mounting process is going to be um
fairly similar stain press is going to
be similar
um it just helps facilitate that cutting
using that uv laser so if you have any
specific questions for your workflow in
particular i'm happy to talk to you
talk more specifics with you
after this
all right thank you
next question
does anyone use lcm for fish experiment
thank you
that is a great question and one that i
do not have the answer off the top of my
head
i will
i will contact you directly
after this with more information
regarding that um apologies i don't have
the answer for you right now
okay
all right next question
how does lcm fit into an ngs workflow
yep so that's a also a very good
question um i'm a field application
scientist for ngs as well so i'm very
familiar with both and how they fit
together um so really lcm is kind of
just used as a sample prep a really
um
a really advanced sample prep but you're
just isolating out those specific cell
populations or tissue types and then
once you have that material you extract
dna out like
you normally would in an ngs workflow
and then you can move through building
um your libraries and then sequencing um
just like you would with you know cell
lysate
or whole tissue scrapes or
any sort of sample material like that so
it fits very easily into the next
generation sequencing workflow
all right
next question what makes the arcturus
different than other lcm systems
um so what differentiates the arcturus
systems really is the dual laser system
so
um other laser capture instruments on
the market right now will either offer
the uv laser or the ir laser but not
both on the same instrument
um so that really aids that flexibility
in the types of tissue that you're able
to
micro dissect
um additionally the way that things are
captured using the archers instrument is
a little bit different from other
um other instruments out there and that
you really maintain custody of your
sample the entire time so once you
capture it stuck on the bottom of that
cap so there's no
there's no movement of your tissue after
that until you're ready to extract it um
so that's another really big advantage
of using the archery system versus
others
great thank you
next question
do you know if there is validated for
clinical workflow for lcm
also can we access the great videos you
showed we are trying to optimize our
sample prep and minimize tissue loss for
clinical ngs workflow
as far as having a validated workflow
from us specifically
we do not um so this is a research use
only instrument at the moment so
um if when we're looking at
actually doing clinical validations um
that's something that i
would have to check if we're able to
help with consulting or anything along
those lines but um but we can definitely
discuss this a little bit more
um
directly after this
all right thank you
next question
does combining a uv laser with an ir
laser increase damage to the rna and dna
um so that's a that's also a very good
question and a super important one when
you're talking about um you know nucleic
acid integrity so the way that the ir
laser works or the uv laser works for me
um so it is going to in that it's about
a two micron line that it's going to
actually you know
it essentially destroys the tissue there
so you want to cut around
tissue that you care about um
so
it's like that barrier that you cut is
essentially going to release it from
that pen membrane so it allows it to
stick to
the cap itself
so you're not going to try and get dna
or rna
from tissue that was
in contact with that laser
um
the ir laser however which is going to
create those tack points of that piece
of tissue
um that is not going to damage your
nucleic acid integrity on that
particular
part of your your tissue
all right thank you
uh
[Music]
next question
what are the different applications
people are using the arcturus for
um yes so that is a great question so
for lcm we really see a wide array of
different applications that it's used
for um obviously oncology is a huge
application because of all the reasons
that i expressed in this presentation
but in addition to oncology one of the
biggest fields that we see using our
technology is neuroscience
um it's a great candidate for lcm
because a lot of the same reasons as
oncology so that need for isolating out
pure populations when you're looking at
endothelial heterogeneity within that
nervous system
um other applications we see are
forensics and um human identification as
well as plant biology actually so um
really any research application where
you need to separate pure populations
would be a really great candidate for
using lcm
all right great thank you
um next question
does the arcturus select need the laser
spot optimized
yes and i i know it can be it can be a
little tedious at the beginning of your
capture um your capture session um but
really it's just to ensure that you know
the laser's firing in the right spot
that it's optimized for
you know your type of tissue the type of
cap you're using i'm just kind of making
sure that before you go to actually
capture your um your tissue that you
know you're going to fire in the spot
that you want it to be
um because you don't want to risk
wasting uh precious tissue especially if
you're looking at archival slides and
things like that where you don't have
the luxury
of a bunch of extra tissue to practice
on so
um that is i know it's tedious but um
you get the hang of it pretty fast
all right
uh next question what sort of customers
would benefit the most from lcm
so i mean that's a very um broad
question so really like i said anybody
who's looking to
you know isolate out those pure
populations so if you're talking cell
culture you can use it for cell culture
to be able to um separate out different
you know clones um when you're looking
at cell lines um you can use it for
isolating out sections of tissue or
individual cells um
so anybody who also has at their
disposal you know those tissue banks
where you've got all of these slides
from you know decades old slides um you
have the ability to go back to that
tissue and investigate it um so it
really you know spans the gamut of
research in general how you can use this
technology
all right great thank you
next question are customers using lcm in
different types of workflow like pcr
yes absolutely so um a lot of our
downstream applications that people are
using it for
are going to be looking at genetic
analysis so whether you're doing
qpcr looking at more targeted gene
expression or if you're doing more of a
almost fishing expedition with next-gen
sequencing or sanger sequencing
it really is a great sample prep option
to feed into all of those genetic
analysis platforms and you're not
restricted to using our platforms as
well so
um you
can you have the freedom to be able to
use lcm for your existing workflows
great
um
next question
uh your email um
what is your email if people would like
to contact you with questions
yes i apologize i did not put that on
the final slide that was
regret i realized after i'd already done
it so um my email is just going to be my
name
katherine.walter
um if you're looking for that spelling
it's on the original lab roots um link
so catherine.walter
thermofisher.com so feel free to reach
out any questions you might have if you
have any you know sales specific
questions i can get you in contact with
the right people as well
great well thank you dr walter do you
have any final comments for our audience
um no just thank you so much for your
attention and i really appreciate you
spending this hour with me i'm looking
forward to talking to some of you and
see how how you're looking to implement
it in your research
thank you again dr walter for your time
today we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand libraries will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
you